are you seeing a trend where
crowdfunding campaigns or maybe a little
harder to reach these days successfully
that maybe they were when crowdfunding
was still relatively new 2010 era
doesn't seem like people are setting
unrealistic goals because they're seeing
high ah maybe maybe I think you know I
think I think early adopters usually
have a plan you know what I'm saying I
think if you're going to jump if you're
like if you see Kickstarter like we did
when we saw the star mind record we said
great we can get two thousand dollars
and do a web series with that you know
that was a couple years ago that we did
that maybe was a little while anyway it
wasn't today and the point is we saw it
we had a need for it thank god someone
made it and now we're going to do it and
I think enough people have done that and
been successful with that where people
who don't have a plan are saying I can
get money for free well that's great
which is how Kickstarter cells
themselves because they want clients
which makes sense except no it's an
investment it's it's a lot of work I've
seen constantly on film courage blogs
about how much work it is and just
you've got to do this you've got to do
that I've made these rules that make it
work and I've made those rules that make
it work and at the end of the day it
goes back to investing in your audience
and building that community and building
that communicates all community building
community building and branding guys are
two different things Hollywood is
learning this lesson the hard way right
now branding you can do in three months
and you have to spend at least 20
million dollars to do it and you can get
people to do whatever you say to a
degree to a point by spending that money
you get all the billboards up and you're
like come see Avengers they all good
idea and you keep seeing it seeing then
you walk into theater you go do it of
course even Avengers you got to give
marble credit cuz they've been building
that audience for 40 years guys that
forty year investment is what made that
movie possible not the two hundred
million dollars it's the fact that
people have been reading about Iron Man
non-stop and Marvel's been
communicating with these guys at comic
books and letters to the editor have
been a constant thing in marvel comics
since the 70s people have known have
been talking to the people who create
captain america since since the 70s you
guys so going back to your point about
social media guess what like Marvel
didn't even get to not do it Disney
didn't even get to not do it they've
been doing it for decades decades and
that is what lets them go out and make a
billion dollars and take it six so
branding is the idea that you can buy
that community is the idea that you can
build building it takes at least two
years it's how it long it took
paranormal activity it's how long it
took people don't realize this but as i
recall napoleon dynamite was picked up
three weeks after it was in theaters by
fox searchlight why per screen averages
they were making money per screen Fox
said wow this movie is doing really well
compared to sideways I want that money
and so they picked it up and put some
more money into it two years of road
showing two years of communicating with
the audience after the film was finished
in both cases same thing for ink inks a
great little movie you know and nobody
knew have much demand that movie had
until it was leaked on piratebay that's
a whole story that is out there on the
internet if you want to look for it but
at the end of the day the roadshow wrote
you at Roadshow festivals festivals
festivals and then the day before their
DVD release or two or three the weekend
before their DVD unit shows up on power
thing and all of a sudden it gets
downloaded four hundred thousand times
and translated into Croatian I'm not
even kidding and all of a sudden amazon
and Blockbuster and whose it's the other
one amazon blockbuster netflix are like
increasing their order by multiples and
they get this big fat hulu deal that was
one of the first movies picked up by
hulu if you recall why because people
watched it because there was an audience
for it they didn't know the audience was
there to that degree until it was leaked
because it was the downloads that showed
them but it was the two years that did
it two years of non-stop and i'm here to
tell you asking people for money as a
community same problem go in with a
long-term plan you know i'm going to get
two hundred thousand dollars this month
is only feasible if that community is
already in place and it's thriving and
people are waiting for you to ask them
which most of us are not
you